many people coming to las vegas for the
labor day holiday orco has a bit more on
what visitors did this weekend and how
they fared getting back home
we were in a lot of restaurants and
shops juan santos who's from florida is
one of many people who visited las vegas
for labor day weekend he spent it doing
the usual gambling a lot
he stopped by the welcome to las vegas
sign before flying home the tsa
estimates that roughly 3.5 million
travelers passed through airports on
friday and saturday alone that's up from
2020 but still fewer than before the
pandemic it's something santos noticed
in vegas a lot slower
a lot of business still closed and
the math all the time still las vegas
was one of the top travel destinations
in the country for labor day weekend
many visitors traveling on the roads
drivers on the i-15 near prim on the way
back to california braving
bumper-to-bumper traffic monday we hate
traffic
travelers tell us they got on the road
earlier to try and avoid the crowds it
takes almost you know an hour to two
hours longer than it normally should be
you know just wanting to get home
quicker and
rest some vehicles drove on the shoulder
to get around others which is not
allowed and not safe that's why some
were glad to travel in groups because i
fall asleep all the time and i can't
leave her i can't leave her drive by
herself you know so i got to stay up and
whether they drove or flew visitors can
agree on one thing i love vegas orcomana
8 news now